thierry coville chercheur à l'iris et
spécialiste de l'iran alors bonjour
merci d'être avec nous on vient
d'écouter le guide suprême qui appelant
les citoyens iraniens à aller voter
à quel point le risque d'abstention et
fort le risque est très élevé
les derniers sondages qui viennent même
des institutions quasi publique
iranienne par disent que 34% des gens
voudraient aller voter si je crois que
c'est quand on considère le tout petit
passe de cette opération le plus bas
jamais enregistré pour une élection
présidentielle me dérange pas que le
dernier taux est et autres outre 70% ça
vous donne une idée de la désaffection
de la population iranienne vis-à-vis de
céder cette élection et pourquoi salle
en vous pour plusieurs raisons preuve
d'abord il ya eu comme vous le savez
depuis le retrait des états unis de
l'accord sur le nucléaire il ya une
crise économique profonde en iran et
donc comme dans n'importe quel pays
la situation économique est tellement
catastrophique que les gens veulent à
leur gouvernement
donc ça je pense que c'est vraiment la
préoccupation première des deux iraniens
il ya également des déceptions
politiques notamment des classes on va
dire urbaine le classe moyenne des
grandes villes qui en veulent quand même
un haro annie de ne pas avoir résisté
plus aux radicaux il à lille elle s'est
un petit peu rangé dans le camp des
radicaux pour la vie et donc ça veut
dire qu elle est d une déception
vis-à-vis de des politiques modérées en
iran sur les ds qu'on appelle les
modérés et puis là la troisième raison
mais qui n'est pas la principale c'est
vrai une énorme sélection qu'on n'a
jamais vu en iran du conseil des
gardiens qui est l'institution chargée
de désigner les candidats aux élections
et dans celles qui ont quasiment rendu
que des candidats radicaux et deux ou
trois candidats modérés mais qui sont
largement inconnu donc dans cette danse
est ensemble d'événements il ya une
désaffection totale des désirs amiens
qui en gros se disait à quoi bon aller
voter
donc la première fois que nos choix du
conseil en aval et d'essai cette
candidature créer une telle polémique
dans le pays
il ya toujours eu des polémiques depuis
des années le conseil des gardiens s'est
arrogé quelques pas le droit de
sélectionner les candidats aux élections
législatives aux élections
présidentielles donc c'est pas nouveau
mais l'engin qui lie à ce point là dans
le sens de ces jeunes et que des
radicaux
ça s'est jamais vu à tel point que même
ali laridjani qui quand même l'ancien
chef du parlement qui est un proche du
guide a même pas été retenu dans cette
liste avec de fines idée de la sélection
qui a été fait est que oui c'était du
jamais vu en iran et il me conseille
dire bienvenue que quasiment que des
condi la très radicaux et très
clairement ouvre la voie à une élection
de rallye sic et l'ancien chef de la
justice environ 5 1 ultra conservateurs
sur les sept candidatures retenues vous
parliez des brahim raïs est justement
qui fait figure de favori d'ultra favori
dans ce scrutin
pouvez vous nous décrire un peu sa
personnalité son parcours alors je pense
qu'il est il est vraiment la figure on
va dire caractéristiques des radicaux
c'est à dire sur le plan si on regarde
ce qu'il a fait en tant qu elle doit
juste en iran c'est une sévérité absolue
faille est quand même dès l'arrestation
de tout tout ce qui est opposition
politique modérée même des syndicalistes
des journalistes
donc avec l'idée qu'à chaque fois
qu'elle contestation du système
politique en iran c'est forcément une
volonté de renverser le régime
donc c'est vraiment la version va dire
sécuritaire qui refuse toute
contestation toute critique du système
politique en iran qu'ils représentent et
donc avec également sur le plan
économique il était responsable d'une
des plus grandes fondations religieuses
en iran la fondation à cette année roth
qui gère le le tombeau de l'imam reza à
mashhad bon tout ça pour dire on est sur
une figure qui sur le plan sécuritaire
jeudi son programme c'est vraiment pas
la démocratie ce ne sont pas les droits
de l'homme il va se concentrer sur
l'économie mais même là peut être
sceptique c'est à dire il vient quand
même un système qui privilégie
privilégie plutôt le clientélisme
vis-à-vis de toute cette organisation
on va dire pour faire court qui
privilégie les fondations et entreprises
appartenant ou passe d'armes en iran
il va se concentrer sur l'économie
peut-être adoucir son image pour
apparaître moins sécurité un oiseau posé
aux droits de l'homme
bon voilà je pense que c'est de ça dont
il va parler aujourd'hui lors du débat
télévisé et la personnalité le président
iranien qui sera élu e s que ça va jouer
sur les négociations en cours à vienne
sur le nucléaire iranien
non pas vraiment comme vous le savez
peut-être tout ce qu'il est les grandes
décisions de politique extérieure en
iran c'est géré par le guide en direct
donc cessé ses négociations sont sous la
direction du guide
donc je crois pas que ça va changer
grand chose
cette élection justement et ses
négociations en cours
cadre aux gars portez-vous dessus un
moment on était plutôt on passe par
toulouse était plutôt optimiste il ya
deux trois semaines là on a l'impression
qu'on rentre dans une phase un peu
concluantes compliquer un peu plus
compliqué on entend aussi que quasiment
de l'accord est quasiment sur la table
donc je pense que c'est toujours ce que
j'ai dit je pense qu'il ya l'idée c'est
comment le faire passer sur le plan
politique
à quel moment il faut l'annoncer je
pense que l'accord est sur la table
il va arriver alors est-ce que ça va
arriver avant les élections
présidentielles en iran ou après
l'élection présidentielle comment il va
être habillée politiquement à la fois en
iran aux états unis ça c'est toute la
question mais je pense qu'on d'après ce
qu'on entend dire faut être prudent on
n'est pas loin d'un accord comme coville
merci pour votre éclairage on appelle
vous êtes chercheur à l'iris et
spécialiste de l'iran vers siel